continuamos en france24 pero ahora vamos
a hablar de economía y estamos para eso
con daniela blandón que nos va a contar
lo más importante en esta materia
daniela el coronavirus llevó a una caída
mundial de los salarios cuéntenos
liliana muy buenas noches en concreto de
este fenómeno afecta a dos terceras
partes del mundo según la organización
internacional del trabajo en los otros
países el salario promedio aumentó pero
en muchos casos de manera artificial
como la mayor parte de los empleos
perdidos son los de menor pago esto hace
que quienes ganan más
lb en el promedio en américa latina'
entre 2014 y 2016 los salarios bajaron
pero desde 2018 se comenzó a anotar una
recuperación que ahora está en peligro
escuchemos pues lo que hemos observado
sobre todo en países como en méxico en
brasil es que en estos casos la pérdida
de los salarios de los asalariados ha
tenido la repercusión de reducir en un
60% los ingresos de las familias donde
están estos asalariados informales
los sectores que están más impactados es
donde la mujer está sobrerrepresentada
en relación a su representación
poblacional dentro de todos los
trabajadores no manera hablamos ahora de
estados unidos que reveló datos
decepcionantes en cuanto a creación de
empleo y no la creación de empleo
privado en noviembre cayó a mínimos
desde junio hasta los 307.000 esto ha
servido como una especie de mecanismo de
presión al congreso para que apruebe un
nuevo plan de estímulos justamente esta
semana revivieron las negociaciones
entre republicanos y demócratas después
de que meses enteros estuvieran
bloqueadas un grupo bipartidista de
legisladores propuso un paquete de
emergencia de 900.000 millones de
dólares esta cifra es una tercera parte
del paquete que se aprobó en marzo por 3
billones de dólares pero cuyos recursos
ya se acabaron ahora todos los ojos
están puestos liliana en un nuevo
salvavidas económico bueno granier
hablamos ahora de américa latina' porque
bolivia empezó este miércoles con la
entrega del bono contra el hambre
si en medio de largas filas inició el
pago de un bono de 143 dólares por
persona esta es una ayuda dirigida a
unos 4 millones de ciudadanos mayores de
18 años que no cuentan con ingresos
entre ellos ancianos sin jubilación o
madres gestantes pero también
discapacitados también es la primera
medida económica del recién posesionado
presidente luís arce durante la entrega
hoy hubo varias aglomeraciones
principalmente en las oficinas del banco
estatal unión esto se debe a que la
entrega coincide con la presencia de
jubilados que por lo general cobran su
mensaje a principio de mes
manila y hablamos de singapur que se
convirtió el primer país del mundo en
aprobar la venta de carne artificial de
pollo si liliana son pequeños trozos de
pollo hechos por la empresa emergente
estadounidense y just en el laboratorios
los ingredientes son en células animales
cultivadas in vitro con migajas de pan y
proteína vegetal esta sería una
alternativa a la carne tradicional que
despierta cada vez más
por razones de salud de cuidado del
medio ambiente y también el bienestar de
los animales y es que tengo unas cifras
muy interesantes liliana según la fao
que es la entidad encargada de alimentos
en naciones unidas el mundo produjo en
2018 unos 341 millones de toneladas de
todo tipo de carne y para 2050 proyecta
que esa producción se habrá duplicado
hoy en día cada persona consume en
promedio 44 kilogramos al año para que
esto suceda se sacrifican anualmente más
de 72 mil millones de animales de ese
total 69 mil millones casi todo son
precisamente pollos de lo que estamos
hablando la entidad dice que si se
mantiene la dieta actual de poco grano
fruta y hortaliza y demasiada carne roja
y elaborada los costos sanitarios
relacionados con la dieta van a alcanzar
1,3 billones de dólares en 2030
a dejar de comer carne entonces de
animales daniela vamos con los
indicadores de la jornada
bueno pues hubo un segundo récord o
consecutivo para el índice standard and
poor's de la bolsa de nueva york que
cerró mixta en europa también hubo
resultados dispares tras los avances en
la vacuna anti kobe y aparte por los
malos resultados laborales de estados
unidos y en américa latina' segunda
jornada positiva para la bolsa de sao
paulo este es por la información
económica ni a dios gracias continúen
con más empresas 24 punto com
[Música]